let's jump over to France where our
celine dion exclusive continues carly
Steele has been in Paris hanging out
with Celine and last night at her
concert backstage things got emotional
I see a fee he's good he doesn't suffer
anymore I think he's enjoying looking
down what absolutely I really do
Renee will be in her heart forever and
she keeps a small memento of him in her
dressing room that's one of the latest
picture was taken thong where was that
at home yeah at home we don't have sad
moments passing away is part of life and
many things help you to go through this
but especially my kids
every show in Paris has been a sellout
and Carly was with her from the moment
she arrived at the arena I feel like
we're Inner Sanctum
with Celine pre-concert like that's
pretty cool
this is definitely free concert you can
even smell the cook we have wonderful
people cooking for us for everybody so
it's a pair of stomach do you have
anything that you really love it's like
kind of your ritual before no I don't
know every trouble I'm trying to be kind
of light oh yeah I'm not too heavy yeah
my my left looking a little bit seen a
bit you get ready for the show guys
later bye bye Celine changes into more
comfy clothes for the soundcheck
then meets and greets some lucky fans
that solution are keeping the atmosphere
light before a show
Celine even rebooted our et theme Allah
Michael Jackson idiot okay are you okey
et that's right fragile time that's her
brother Michelle who leads her to the
stage and we are right there as the
curtain is lifted
never more glamorous surprise Selene
does her own stage makeup I don't use
false eyelashes because two things if I
use them for specific on a couple of
songs I will use individuals because if
I lose one it won't show if I use a
stripe and I lose it and I blink and
it's in my forehead over here suddenly
she's got a mustache
I'm not good the scandal Celine Dion's
mid-show mustache beard is amazed after
Paris next is on de Montreal for ten
show starting July 31st and she's
working on a new album and dropped a big
scoop just for you ok think we're old
knee or something yeah she's a nominal
she is phenomenal I love her for her
talent for her strength for her focus
the person she is the BMA's when I saw
her I said for you to take the time to
really write a song to give me a tool
piece of luggage to help me to move
forward to walk to keep going um it's
called
recovery oh wow wow
get ready
my gosh